eh bien vous jour les amis et bienvenue
dans cette vidéo making of de la vidéo
rainbow six sièges je suis avec théo qui
est le réalisateur de la vidéo et avec
julien qui a coécrit avec moi comme la
vidéo n'est pas sorti au moment où on
fait ce making-of faq je peux pas
demander aux gens de me poser des
questions parce qu'ils n'ont pas vu la
vidéo et en plus à l'aspect y tout ce
que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai écris moi
même des questions donc je vais me poser
des questions à nous mêmes c'est parti
pour la
robert question quand avez vous commencé
à bosser sur ce projet moi j'ai souvenir
d'avoir fait une vidéo avec vous on
regarde du bollywood petit replay avant
après quoi c'est les viols de mecs
pendant l'hiver et la d re fois c'était
juste avant l'été on avait commencé à
bosser sur ce projet à ce moment là
sachant que le projet avait été évoqué
avec ubisoft en février donc ça a mis
dix mois à 100 pourquoi avoir choisi de
faire un court métrage d'action au début
l'idée de départ il me semble c'était de
faire un clip come over butch exactement
pas la balle je crois qu'il fallait
faire un nouveau en doute comme on a
fait pour assassins comme zelda comme
howard bowles est en gros l'idée c'est
de faire je joue à rainbow six et puis
quand j'avance dans les couloirs hockey
enfin et comme pour faire un exemple moi
je suis la recrue j'ai pas trop
d'expérience et toi tu es fusent
tu mets des grenades dans les murs a
donc les réactions des gens devant sa
bave voilà votre réaction
je pense que l'univers de rainbow six il
est un peu plus réaliste il est arcade
un peu mais il est un peu plus réaliste
qui fait qu'on pouvait pas se permettre
voilà deux le québec trop frontalement
car j'ai vu qu'on est tous des grands
fans de roxy est aussi le réalisateur du
clip ce match tellement fan que je
connais bien ma terminale mais ouais en
fait on se disait plus tard une occasion
de faire une [ __ ] de scènes d'action
avec une musique un peu pop tout ça pas
de gagner un peu de fun un univers quoi
de créer un décalage nouvelles questions
que s'est il passé avec tes cheveux
julien bailly lors du matin écoute il ya
eu qui te pose d'un petit produit comme
ça ça donne un côté gryffondor un petit
peu et tu t'es pas demandé après cette
question n'avait pas de rapport avec
rainbow six noms et c'est la chargée de
préparer ces nakba qui a fait son moi je
suis là pour vous avez tourné
c'est vrai qu'il ya un grand décor
plusieurs salles démarche la grande
salle etc
on a tourné ou tout ça alors on a tourné
à qui aime bien un studio dans lequel on
a tourné tous énormément de choses vous
internet comme par exemple ça plaît bien
il a écrit à un truc avec une 3 ou en
gros il fallait qu'ils aient des murs
particulier des pièces particulières
qu'on puisse faire les actions entre
elles ont du coup on a dû faire un plan
très précis de tout ce qu'on voulait on
a reconstruit tout le décor de hasard
quoi tous les murs que vous voyez dans
l'image ce faux les portes les fenêtres
permet de créer l'illusion que c'était
là et on avait besoin aussi d'avoir des
faux murs des trucs parce que dans le
jeu on n'est plus vraiment quoi
on pouvait pas casser de vrai mur
nouvelle question c'est vous qui avez
fait les costumes
alors maintenant city oui je paye c'est
moi alors non c'était qu'au super je
connais pas le nom par coeur mais il se
sent le chalet croix sur la tête de théo
ces gens là qui ont fait tous les
costumes donc avertis costume avec les
costumes étaient champ mais regardez on
peut mettre maintenant à l'écran making
of des petites photos compare les persos
du jeu et nous dans la vraie vie qui
limite les persos du jeu
[Musique]
joli programme bon apparemment l'intimé
cup naturel très léger un effet bonne
mine en fait
je ne connais pas du tout le jeu
français s'appelle rainbow parce que
c'est un jeu avec des arcs en ciel et
qui cornes découvre mc lyte sans cheveux
[Musique]
bref voilà un très beau travail
j'ai pas l'air d'un moniteur de ski a
plutôt l'air du gars qui bat verbe
moniteur de ski je vais passer mon
étoile en commun vraiment pas respecté
on m'a mis
le pq vide au bout de mon fait voilà
comment voulez vous j'ai une crédibilité
trois fois en or le mail du ray direct
pas l'emmerder la fin j'ai peut-être de
gentils d'habitude vous m'avez rendu
méchant il ya une réflexion collective
qui veut que lendemain grant sachez que
l' inverse complètement valable
également
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir des enfants
pourquoi n'avoir coup sûr tout le monde
fait tout pour que je me sens le loin
possible du classement étaient deux
choses dans le duo vanessa aurait été le
seul choc du duo juge
[Musique]
le perso ne faut pas appeler à des
ramiers galère un peu à s'équiper tu
peux être là demain
ok demain c'est moche
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est mon perso et samoa aux
kabyles aux cabines croyable génial
c'est la palme la seule difficulté c'est
que dans le jeu il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont le visage couvert et
pour qu'on reconnaisse les guest et les
acteurs ben on a retiré les masques par
exemple ce net on a accroché son masque
à la poitrine pour qu'on comprenne que
c'est sledge fois pareil la nature ça
sur la bouche d'un bref mais globalement
on comprend quand même qui est qui et ce
truc cool alors une belle question alors
que theo est célibataire
oui
[Musique]
e
qui a composé la musique
la maman suivait dans sa jeunesse un
groupe qui s'appelait les frénétiques ce
voilà dans les années 80 m l'a fait
écouter plusieurs fois sa musique elle
aime énormément et en fait c'est un
groupe qui est très peu connue que
jamais trompé recettes donc un gros bide
au groupe frénétique s'ils sont tous
dans l'anonymat aujourd'hui puisqu'ils
ont fait 200 à l'époque mais sont
hautement et j'en sais rien bref en fait
je voulais que le court métrage choix
rythmée sur musique des années 80 comme
techonomy aau maniaque mais sauf que les
droits coûte très très cher mais les
fans de musique c'est à 80 moins connus
et prime j'ai repensé à ce truc là que
ma mère suivait quand j'étais plus jeune
donc on a contacté la maison de disques
on a eu les droits pour pas très cher et
du coup cette chanson là comme un acteur
sa jeunesse des années plus tard je
l'utilisé mois dans une
comment vous y êtes pris pour écrire le
scénario
c'est un peu la partie de ça c est
julien le docteur tout le monde à moi je
suis stagiaire mais j'ai beaucoup écrit
pour une fois sur toute l'année je
disais mais c'est stylé si lui il
interagit avec lui de cette manière et
qui se passe ça observé dans son oreille
comme ça et j'en reparlerai du cros
s'est transformée moi je déballe je lis
et je regarde t on chez ces faisabilité
m c'était une idée de toi je viens de
dire qu'un au début faisons parce que tu
joues qui part de son côté comme ça on
peut créer de situations parallèles tu
vois ce qu'ils sont encore bloquées dans
le piège et few ce qui est en train
d'attaquer les défenseurs avec sa
machine à grenade donc sa part et faire
des va-et-vient entre deux situations
c'est trop bien la recrue c'était cool
comme personnage quoi d'avoir un
personnage de mecs qui découvre qu'à pas
de pouvoir faire découvrir l'univers du
jeu que moi j'aime beaucoup plus on a
vraiment coécrit tous ensemble cette
vidéo je voulais trop bien vraiment
grâce où les trois essais un marché tout
de suite
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur à gérer
dans la réalisation de ce projet le
tempérament lucas laure ce qui était dur
mais on l'a vu en écrivant ce qu'il
fallait qu'on écrive un truc mais sur
une musique etc a rien à voir
il fallait qu'on arrive à faire entrer
toutes les actions en rythme avec la
musique mais une fois que les deux amis
si on écrit un truc qui était juste pas
faisable
une réunion de muri la tête on se
connaît pas forcément compte de toutes
les actions vu qu'à très peu de
dialogues il fallait que toutes les
actions rendre dans des phases de
parfois 25 secondes quoi ou à
l'avancement j'avais fait un shooting
board il y avait à chaque fois toutes
les actions montent et en musique pour
toute l'équipe se rendent compte de qui
doit faire quoi à quel moment quoi
[Musique]
et ouais c'est la difficulté en fait
c'était de faire de l'action sur une
musique qui appellent toute l'action
rien touché pour cet opus physique
anecdotes j'avais dans ma besace une
carte à jouer sur cette question je n'ai
rien touché parce que j'ai tout remis
dans la prod pour qu'on puisse réaliser
qu'on voulait faire et ça a coûté très
cher j'ai mis cette question pour qu'ils
puissent raconter si tu es vraiment un
patois juste pour donner un ordre d'idée
normalement pour une vidéo de genre si
cette mue qui ont une journée en fiction
là pour une vidéo de quatre minutes
on attendait 3 jours qu'on tellement il
ya de plans différents les décors les
personnes lors des actions et tout ça
combien de temps at il fallu pour faire
les effets spéciaux ça c'est une très
bonne question parce que moi quand je
vois un film c'est plein de trucs que je
me dis une fois quand tout ça à plus
trois semaines c'est guillaume grifoni
le sultan des effets spéciaux et à
s'occuper de quasiment tous les films de
ce film qui a pas mal de taton à des
hologrammes on va avoir de l'explosion
des pages exposant les
qui fait mal au dos l'impact de la
grosse répètera plus grosse vidéo sur
laquelle on a donc été aussi parce que
nous on a cru qu'on trouvait ça cool
s'il y avait des fixes réel les impacts
de balles sur le mur connaît la
fusillade entre les deux équipes il y
avait vraiment des petits explosif dans
le mur qui explosait sur le tournage
avait l'impression qu'ils avaient les
pattes qui a traversé le mur c'était
génial plus courtes ou sanitaire en
série entre aider at war mans donc là
pour une centaine d'euros avec le
deuxième film why à la batterie oh
certes à tata et des paroles parce que
vous voyez un mur avec des types qui
explosent mais daniel est très bien
équipé
en fait si tu es un peu notre xylophone
ya donc là ça va exploser à 5 cm de nos
jeux doit pas regarder parce qu'à des
jets de peinture et je peux perdre à
neige est-ce que julien a l'habitude de
monter des murs de la sorte et non c'est
vrai que tu as une certaine maîtrise
dans la vidéo sur weblin vrai j'ai pris
sur moi c'est qui fit notre chef
cascadeur cascade sur la je pense qu'il
est cascadeur est non alors bonjour et
tracté par un petit moteur électrique et
à la ceinture mais ici on va le tracter
à la main regardez bien suivi à ses
lecteurs de l'accord sa fin dans une
poulie torino et la corde redescend ici
aurait dragué cobas toute la difficulté
va résider dans le fait qu il doit faire
genre qu'il est à l'aise
ce n'est pas du tout à l'aise et
maintenant quelques images de julian
rappel est il à l'aise selon douch c'est
parti
de passage à niveau petit un peu moins
un petit tir bien vous fait ce dernier à
chantilly seront apaisées
[Musique]
le truc c'est que je vois rien mais bon
son avec ça glisse un peu à gauche
c'était plus facile aux claviers
cette phrase est de combien de temps tu
as dû répéter avant de réussir à faire
ta cascades squeeze ça m'a demandé pas
mal de temps mais heureusement j'ai fait
trois ans de gymnastique donc niveau la
détente la position a l'air tout ça je
connais un peu ça m'a fait penser à mon
service militaire aussi donc j'ai pas
trop galérer non plus bouger la scène la
plus stylée je suis content de l'avoir
fait est juste dommage que les taux
évoluent que j'ai une cagoule à ce
moment là ça peut être un peu les
couilles j'aurais aimé qu'on voit mon
visage par enfin bon c'est pas grave en
tout cas j'ai bon quand même pas dit
avant que saint etienne mois depuis le
début je dis à tout le monde c'est moi
qui l'ait fait non mais en fait tu l'as
fait mais l'été c'était pas où nous
sommes avec marc barr va faire la
cascade au moment où j'arrive en rappel
et je peux être là pas les synthés où
j'étais comme mais en fait je dégote
rien du tout je vais juste regarder
marqué tout faire des petites cordes qui
a été attaché avec une poulie ccrp
presse à part dont vraiment j'arrive de
l'immeuble pour faire ses jeux j'ai fait
tout est ok et orcières pas comme cause
de ça d'accord qui allez on va sur sa
tombe a été galère c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'il faisait fallait remettre tous
les morceaux de planches je les regrette
tout ça pour qu'il puisse leur faire et
on avait du retard sur la journée ne pas
me laisser et il ya un des trois essais
qui fut très périlleuse c'était le
deuxième parce que les mails qui connaît
la corne se sont dit on va lâcher
pendant qu'il fait ça comme ça au lieu
d'aller vers le haut il ira tout droit
un peu plus les on achète trop tôt et ça
a donné ça
proto mais bon à part ce fait ils ont
trop gérer la roue là aussi c'est de
marquer la fête ils ont trop gérer
l'équipe de cascadeurs ou que bravo à
eux est ce que les armes tirées vraiment
un pote dans ce genre de film quand tu
prends les images de base des rushes
quoi et du coup moins un montage je fais
une première passe gérer c'est de
rajouter plein peints en gris mais
derrière c'est clément morin c'est le
montage son et c'est lui qui a repris
chaque geste mais parfois c'est juste un
bruit de frein encore un but pas d'âme
je me répète c'est important de parler
de ça parce que s'il n'y a pas ça on n'y
croit pas du tout regardé la vidéo avec
au 15 août design juste le son de la
camsa partie [ __ ] de merde
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] de mer
clément s'est rajouté un milliard de son
en plus un fan du jeune il est beau et
connaître le jour et toi aussi dit rambo
et il est très bonne on est chaud comme
à mon avis le connaissant lycées la
petite connerie dedans il a glissé d'un
bruit de muay-thaï n'y a pas de moi je
trouvais le bruit vers la sphère là et
gagner notre respect déclaration d'amour
c'est super parce que déjà sur overblog
j'avais appris beaucoup de choses kembo
pareil j'ai appris plein de trucs et
tout et c'est hyper stimulant pour moi
merci beaucoup c'était une très bonne
aventure humaine même j'ai rencontré
plein de gens géniaux sur le tournage je
pense que nous avons répondu à toutes
les interrogations des genres si y en a
d'autres et ce n'est pas les poser dans
les commentaires et peut-être que je
faisais à certains on espère donc la
vidéo vous a plu on peut pas savoir à
l'heure actuelle ça fait chier ça m'a
énormément mais merci pour votre accueil
si ça vous a plu
et aussi ça vous a pas plu tant pis on a
donné le meilleur de nous et on a beau
donner le meilleur de soi-même et 2 dire
que ça va être bien c'est pas forcément
c'est comme ça c'est la création
merci à vous les gars gros kiff et puis
on se retrouve très bientôt pour de gros
projets ont déjà tueur ouais merci à
vous regarder la vidéo il n'était pas
passé par la chaîne de julien ici
présents afin de voir inviter le site
doté auchan drive the box d'axel un max
d'actu et à vous avoir agi de youtube
pour ce qu'impose une prochaine vidéo a
très vite la famille
[Musique]
cette pression là dedans
hahaha
ce qui arrive quand on joue le jeu de la
violence et que ça peut se retourner
contre vous j'adore me paraît si le
texte
ça s'est bien passé
[Applaudissements]
voilà rassurés alors les gars bien alors
là plus personne
[Musique]